dans les locaux de la production
ambiance studieuse l'équipe s'affaire à
la préparation de l'événement plus
exactement à sa refonte car initialement
c'est à saint pierre le mois prochain
que devait se dérouler la série de
concerts la rumeur annoncé un report de
l'événement c'est désormais officiel les
francofolies 2021 se dérouleront du 1er
au 10 octobre à saint leu au vu du
contexte sanitaire actuelle il devenait
compliqué de faire une implantation veut
le nombre de flux qu'on a sur l'entrée
est
le l'erp et salue donc la ravine ça leur
offrait ses prestations là pour pouvoir
nous réorganiser contenu du coc vide les
francofolies sont nés à saint pierre ya
cinq ans pour devenir avec le sac il
faut un des rendez vous culturel phare
de la réunion
une page d'histoire se tourne mais pas
question de tourner définitivement le
dos à saint-pierre selon les
organisateurs 10 ans aucun
n'y a aucun souci aujourd'hui on parle
toujours avec la mairie de saint pierre
il ya un problème à ça le déménagement
à la base temporaire sur saint leu
définitifs ont ensuite parce que c'était
plus simple par rapport à l'événement ne
change en rien les relations avec la
mairie de saint pierre
sakifo n'a pas dit quand rougé il n'ya
que franco qui bouge en apprend vite
quitté cette ville la fois venir l'an
dernier vingt mille personnes se sont
rendues aux francofolies en trois jours
sur le site de la ravine blanche à saint
pierre avec les jauge réduite et la
limitation à deux mille places assises
en extérieur la nouvelle formule saint
leusienne se déroulera sur dix jours en
fonction bien évidemment d'ici là de
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire